[Music]
there is growing concern this morning in
many cities about a rise in violent
crime nationally homicide rates
increased by 24 percent at the beginning
of this year
compared with a prior year and that
includes larger cities like new york and
chicago
and smaller cities like omaha and
louisville addressing rising crime was a
key focus for
bill bratton the former head of the
boston los angeles and new york city
police departments
and he's out with a new book on the
changing face of policing
and the reforms that he put in place
it's called the profession a memoir of
community
race and the arc of policing in america
we should mention we're happy to mention
that mr bratton is married to cbs news
legal analyst ricky clement
commissioner good morning to you great
to be here with you great to be here
it's really great to have you here
terrific to have you at the table
unfortunate to have you at the table at
a time when we've got crime rates going
up
in many big cities you oversaw historic
declines in multiple cities what would
you do now
well the timing of the book is uh
perfect in that respect because
basically it's a tutorial
what worked what didn't work over the
last 50 years and we're in the midst of
a crime crisis once again
as we're coming away from the
coronavirus crisis and uh
we don't have to reinvent that there's
lessons that have been learned
that can address not only crime but also
the parallel
race relations that we can do both at
the same time we must
so i mean on on that question systemic
racism
in policing comes up constantly at this
table all across the country people are
talking about it
is it present in policing your answer is
yes but
what's the but yes but in that it's not
present everywhere
fortunately it's like our society that
systemic racing
uh systemic racism is present in almost
every element of our society our country
i appreciate you even mentioning that
it's present most people your stature
don't even acknowledge that it exists
how do you how do you deny our history
yeah in history that we're still living
out today with some of the politics of
today
the vote of suppression is basically a
lot of that is based on systemic racism
really is you detail in one of the most
powerful chapters in the book the
implicit bias training
that nypd officers go through and it is
truly impressive stuff
and yet you look at the record in the
city and there's been more than a
billion dollars
in payouts and settlements in line of
duty deaths where officers kill the
suspect
uh what do you make of that discrepancy
thank you for raising that we spent a
lot of money putting all 36 000 officers
through four days of training to make
them aware
of implicit bias but to actually do
something about it requires training
and a major focus of the book is that we
need to
refund police not defund that we're
going to need a lot more money to
retrain
to deal with bias to deal with the
homeless to deal with the emotionally
disturbed
commissioner one of the biggest sticking
points on federal police reform
is what's called qualified immunity and
holding officers accountable
what changes would you support to
qualified immunity
more importantly i think the police
profession police leadership are willing
to support
some changes in qualified immunity you
can't do away with it that
it is so critically important to the
morale of officers but also
in some respects of their livelihood but
it can be reformed
two key words dealing with qualified
immunity it's one
that the action has to be lawful in two
that the officers have to basically
uh be aware that what they're doing is
uh uh what a reasonable person would do
it's a very misunderstood
term and concept and i'm glad it's out
there being discussed
yeah i am too i i like that you said uh
implicit bias
is not a a is a human issue not a law
enforcement issue
but i think to follow up on anthony's
point most people
certainly people of color are upset
because it doesn't seem that police are
held accountable
most times in these situations you're
meeting people on your worst possible
day
the officers will say well don't resist
just do what we say they're trained to
maintain authority
we've got to figure out a way to see
each other in this in this time and we
don't do that
let's read alice harris to see each
other the good news about this is that
we have been reforming i talk about that
in the book that we've been reforming
for 50 years so we have more
accountability than we did
we have better training than we did
isn't that the issue or do you think the
issue is better training de-escalation
in particular they're the professionals
well i think
the training is the key to build trust
and it's essential to build trust
you're going to have to have better
training better accountability your
target
better transparency and we now have
capabilities there with the cameras that
they're all carrying no uh this is an
inflection point and let's
not get it long this time because we've
gotten so much wrong in the past
i'm very excited about the opportunities
out of the crisis of the moment well you
wanted to be a cop since you were a
toddler out there directing traffic
bought your first cop book at 11. you
said you love cops love being a cop but
you know there's work to do i know the
flaws yeah and the book is dedicated to
22
000 officers who have died in the line
of duty you say those cops count
police matter and if people are
interested in the police perspective
this certainly gives it to them
well thank you commissioner thank you
very much the book is the profession and
goes on sale tomorrow